welcome back to the show I do want to
update you on what's going on with the
YouTube advertiser boycott known as
YouTube ad pocalypse now colloquially uh
it's been a while since I've talked
about this and we're sort of getting to
the point of figuring out what the
permanent situation will be and it's
really not good okay the backstory is
that on March 31st instantly we lost
ninety-nine percent of our YouTube
revenue which in and of itself
represented about half of the revenue
for our program okay the reason for this
was that some uh ads showed up on racist
videos they were screenshotted by a
couple of different news outlets
including the Wall Street Journal huge
deal was made over it
Wow YouTube can't control where ads are
showing up now the problem was that the
article suggested that YouTube's ad
algorithm was 2 lakhs
the reality was the opposite that videos
for example advocating against
anti-semitism were seen as the same as
anti-semitic videos by the YouTube ad
algorithm it was a too strict algorithm
so again trying to solve a problem that
didn't exist we lost 99% of our revenue
as a result because anything we do could
be interpreted as sort of controversial
right when we talk about Russia or Isis
or whatever if you have a view that uh
anytime someone talks about Isis it's
basically the same as Isis propaganda
even if you're talking about a strategy
to defeat Isis uh then you're going to
lose ad revenue on that basis and that's
what happened we lost ninety-nine
percent of our ad revenue that was March
31st April 11th for a couple days it
popped back up to about 15% of the
revenue we had been experiencing then on
April 13th back down to almost nothing
mid to late April I think it was April
eighteenth or nineteenth a New York
Times article came out about what was
going on with our channel and nothing
happened at the end of April we started
seeing a little bit of an uptick and
right now we're basically in a in a more
permanent stable state where we are
earning a third of what we were earning
before we've lost about two thirds of
our YouTube revenue and
it appears as though that is going to be
more or less permanent our situation is
we're getting about two-thirds the
number of ads that we used to have and
each one of those ads is paying about
half of what it used to pay two-thirds
the ads each pays half that means we are
right at about one third of the revenue
we used to earn unfortunately we've been
sort of waiting around for this to
self-correct unfortunately there's a new
article on tube filter comm it's a
website that publishes news about
platforms like YouTube and they are
basically saying this is it quote from
that article the big picture trends in
the digital video business plus the
changes to YouTube's algorithm we saw
last year point to something far larger
and potentially permanent the old
YouTube is not coming back because
YouTube is no longer interested in just
being YouTube featuring and catering to
its homegrown creators of the past
decade the future of YouTube is YouTube
TV and to a lesser degree YouTube red
and the future is suddenly now yet this
bigger that yet this trend is bigger
than just YouTube none of the large
public company digital video platforms
are interested in focusing on
individuals digital creators anymore all
of them are moving upmarket to focus on
TV or on TV like content with longer
formats and more advertiser friendly
subject matter this is happening right
at the same time that the larger media
companies are unbundling their content
and looking to broadcast on mobile and
the web these moves show no signs of
ending or reversing and in fact they
follow well-known patterns in the
business world it's bad and sadly I
don't even want to do this now but I'll
mention it we're probably going to lose
our Amazon affiliate revenue as well I
don't want to dig into that too much but
just Google what's been happening to
similar creators with their ad revenue
on or their affiliate revenue on Amazon
this is huge for us I mean that this
this is really really bad for us and
I've not been talking about this to try
to not fatigue people in the audience
but I I'm sort of at no
I have no choice now but to come to you
and say this is permanent and we need
your help okay
so there's a few things you can do
number one membership membership is huge
you can sign up at david pakman.com
slash membership you get the bonus show
you get a commercial free audio and
video stream of the show just for our
members and lots of great things but you
also are supporting our work ok david
pakman.com slash membership we have a
coupon code available that'll save you
40% that coupon code is I voted 17 ok
please sign up for membership we're
talking about only a few dollars a month
number two
patreon ok patreon is simpler than
membership you just make a pledge of any
amount you want we've got just over
1,500 patrons right now you go to
patreon.com slash david pakman show we
estimated we were making thirty to fifty
cents for each viewer that was watching
all hundred and sixty of our monthly
videos if you pledge just a dollar you
can replace that lost revenue and uh if
we can get a few more thousand people to
do that work fifteen hundred right now
we will actually make up for all of the
lost YouTube revenue so please do that I
already mentioned if you shop on Amazon
david pakman.com slash amazon if you
have youtube read watch our videos we
will get a slice of that youtube read
fee and number five you can get david
pakman show gear coffee bumper stickers
t-shirts hoodies at david pakman.com
slash gear the good news is the patreon
donors are accumulating as you can see
we are beyond 1500 patrons there I don't
care what you donate this is a
cumulative process even if you can only
donate $1 a month please do it because
if everybody does it then we will fix
this problem and actually come out ahead
and way more independent than we ever
were and the good news about membership
is that people are signing up you can go
to david pakman.com slash membership you
can select a monthly or yearly
membership click on the red sign up
button then you can enter the coupon
code
I voted 17 on the second page of the
sign up and that will save you 40% and
by the way we are
still doing the targeted front patreon
goal if and when we get to 2,000 patrons
and I think it's a matter of when not if
I hope anyway we're under 500 patrons
away I will do an entire show in studio
with my hair similar to what we're
showing our TV and YouTube audience
right now this is what happens when I
put no product in my hair it's a scary
sight for many it may not be a
kid-friendly show because we it's the
stuff of nightmares from what I'm being
told but I will do an entire show in
studio with my hair like this and if you
don't care about that don't worry about
it we are just trying to build a base of
support and you can do that at
patreon.com slash david pakman show I'm
gonna try to sporadically check in with
you about this I can't mention it every
day I get that people will get fatigued
but this is a big hit this is a big hit
for us and as a result I do need to on
some semi-regular basis remind you that
things have changed on our n financially
and we do need your support